welcome back to CBS this morning it is a
party in the USA because its fourth of
July gotta have a hamburger hotdog at
some point during the day myself it's
time to bring you some of the stories
that we call the talk of the table swine
so this is where we each pick a story
that we'd like to share with each other
and with all of you you want to go first
to Rica well sure go first
a New York woman left a $5,000 tip for
her waitress last month the problem is
she used her boyfriend's credit card I'm
gonna assume maybe ex-boyfriend by now
yeah in an act of revenge against him so
listen to this her boyfriend at the time
got into an argument and essentially she
used his credit card she had breakfast
they got into an argument because she
wanted him to buy a ticket for her to
get to New York he said no no so she is
going okay so apparently she had access
to this credit card she used it on a 55
dollar breakfast let's just start with
the $55 breakfast right so then the tip
is ten thousand percent of the bill five
thousand five thousand dollars and this
is what's really crazy the restaurant
has already paid out the waitress and
the police say it is up to the waitress
and the restaurant as to whether or not
she has to give the tip back and for the
very like interesting since a long piece
and all of this yeah
today the waitress told a local
affiliate she thought that it was a kind
gesture because she just put her dog
back so she took this tip going no she
was pissed at her boyfriend well then I
don't think it's totally waking the
waitress thought maybe oh okay I got it
I got it here's a question should the
waitress give the money back I think she
should I don't know it is a lot of and I
think maybe the the the gentleman who
has the credit card maybe should give
her a hundred yeah yeah I I don't think
that's right number one she put it on
the card it's not really her card if she
was arrested for felony theft the the
girlfriend she turned herself in I loved
her expression in the mug shot she's
like yeah it was me
so you don't think she should give the
money back I'm undecided I don't think I
can adjudicate this on the people think
there might be a new law in which you
can't you know a certain percentage that
could come out of this who knows but I
just I've never heard of such thing and
that's a good gracious tip that's a good
what again that's not nice